And these are all yes, no questions.
Question number one, does the, the word order matter inside of a phrase?
Yes or no?
Do long text or phrases give fundamentally different input vectors?
Or put differently, if I just take the same email and make ten copies and
put all the ten copies into a,
like the same text, will I get something different, yes or no?
And finally, can we really handle complex phrases involving multiple words?
Classic example in the US is Chicago Bulls is actually a sports team,
where Chicago itself is just a city, and Bulls is an animal.
But the conjunction of these two words means something entirely different from
the words insulation.
Again, yes or no?
Give it a try.